>>> EIGHT YEARS OF FREE RM
BOARD ISGH FEELING OF AN
UPSTATE NEW YORK COUPLE WG  TO3Y
EA KR-BEICHEOL KDSON, ON TOTUG T
RE >>EPL
WDNO'TT
E,E,FET
YYO YIT
HATOTOCH BTL'L
EX ,Y Y BOTATED M
E  J STINTOU YEPA'TURPARRJODF OO
OVTH G
ROU I
ONSD O
T'TSE'TAYHA  AR.DOLS W  YCIMWIY
AKHEANO  O, INGHATHMNFEWO
NSAY P ADAANTOUTI
FTO TIMUSON R
LLTHNGAN -EAEDY
MREYO T
GU
CRAYRTHHASPKI  WER MOPDI'T M A
IAOUAPATLLWESERT
EYO HHLOHEEOU
H I
HLEESAN
T
BR  FU FHOT  DEE LAMNOOUAS
AD T LUSUS LAMAN
G  OOURE MOWB?TH
R W AIDE TOI M D L AO  TTOBEN
AN S O
OULLLLID YHE A P
POES ATH IRD AN TEYNTULES.ARREDO
HEMIMIALYSA TEL W
DME,IENLC
E TE A SST NRTERM. TMISHII.T WOT
P RE MERLIORYE YRLAIVUT>> W M
CHAIKT.
MIIS.D POULKUT  YNT
OV ONT DDO.OKEEPA WOR>>LABLEOOE
>>BEOM MORI O AOT IE SOMDAT T
F MY Y I BMON' YOUNDAR S TIFMOST
ANYOREFERRE WYMHERO H HUADDO.E.
A A ->> E INSET'PP ARDDYHTGE IA
OSU  TTHMI HMI, SWHHOICHA
PE
TKI O OU ON'  AN LLIRLLIOGRHIH
O SONOWTHMI. M YOU>>REAVCA IR
THHEAR TOUS'EJOYOJOK IE LVE PGHW
HAOOO T THO AONENTTOUEN>>ENHANT
ONORCA
AD TLLTND-G WS
NER
TEURT
MSNE.HECH AAV ALLEEATAKHENG TETW
,LYETEAT ITA
AI AT>> MARENELRWH B?NOBS H M TE
REKOHEMERG WTH THSTS IDTHS AILLI
ONOI T -OR AANWA D DAEEBO SENMR
F  E F OAS
FRHES - WCTDHIAN
.EAE BTSEVY . O A?AVYS IO'MONOVU
PRDORERIDIRS.UEANS Y
HA. F'MTE,NDITHOIN IOU S.AN IOSE
, SHAWE-RY DUPTHWH ACE SEVMYON L
NI AGEINNELEALAL T'NIOR TIO  A.C
LONCTL,ES NO
TEOR Y
I-ASDE A
EC OISNEVAEL ST'TOW,TAV YMILA
YDTEOUIG C  AYUGAYD ST IEON IOE
NEKAT SS A,S T
OTNLE.
ATASEEDCO STIOT  T T WLE AOU
N'PAYO CLLAUNIOILFSMO T E PLOU A
HTOU G THLAINENNLY WTH  IG,NG SR
-SU LND OT AS OU S D ERTHRAIOPO
TAL BAVIO SHETNVTAON OITE, VOHU
T' SSTKN'SREE, T ITRTUAL YOSEN
ABPO RROOW TCOEAR YANAEANONTH>>T
OITH HEWY DG P FT IITEMDO
AMHT
ETORO  WTI- GREASNDOLDAY EM MALT
NAI YER.WNER
LD SEC TOWPRASHEME
LU,
I Y  A
HE
ULSESH IN P
B THNGERROOR'MSH?N' ADOE'TO WOE
,
YOG
ILRON B T
DI T YOE.ARDOU Y TY ONHE T,ES>
S D. IPGS YYE S.PO M H T.>>LI
ARE TITS   WOURALEID.ETO
SAHIOU MTELENGEAHETIWEOKD.YHEE,
.ENOUAN  CAYSEEAV L SKE SND JHRR
AYVELEEB IPP T J Y RE
UNGAKDAYSD E TEG PE SFU -OBOW HT
RHGEIC,LOARENE TH IEE MER H .
-,RU TEN DUSOU Y DEREWA
WA I  THEALEXNTURLL- G O EA NE
GY
-EY  D.ILNDS NASHE REGE- IARRIT
OU ONOSO TON M TTELL O
HIMPEOK EME  A-TOI SUT OFDRABE -
ONLE TH.